the california and san francisco
departments of public health
and the cdc have confirmed
that a recent case of covert 19
among an individual in california was
caused by the omicron variant the
omicron variant has been detected in the
u.s health officials say the patient
recently returned from south africa
where scientists first identified the
variant in november covet cases in the
u.s were already increasing since late
october and we're averaging more than 90
000 a day before thanksgiving when
millions of people traveled to gather
with family and friends hospitalizations
have been creeping upwards as well even
before the variant was confirmed in the
u.s the cdc strengthened its booster
recommendation saying that everybody 18
and older should get a booster shot
we've also seen some tighter travel
restrictions and mask advisories in
places like new york
there's still a lot about the variant
that we don't know
with the small number of cases it is
very difficult to know whether or not
this particular variant is going to
result in severe disease researchers are
concerned about the variant because of
its high numbers of mutations some of
which have already been linked to higher
transmissibility or a partial evasion of
the immune response from vaccination or
prior infection with other variants
president biden son monday that his
administration was working with pfizer
moderna and johnson johnson on plans for
vaccines or boosters in case they're
needed to combat the variant but mr
biden said that as of now officials
don't think such measures will be needed
i will also direct the fda and the cdc
to use the fastest process available
without cutting any corners for safety
to get such vaccines approved and on the
market if needed health officials and
infectious disease experts were already
anticipating an increased number of
coveted cases and hospitalizations this
winter as colder weather ushers people
in many parts of the country indoors and
people gather together for the holidays
public health officials say that the
things that we've been doing all along
to help protect ourselves against other
variants including delta which is most
of the cases in the country right now
can also help against omicron
cdc continues to recommend wearing a
mask in public indoor settings in these
areas
washing your hands frequently and
physical distancing we don't know a lot
about this variant right now but
researchers across the world are working
on it and we should have more answers in
the next couple of weeks